MIGHT HAVE TRIED TO TAKE OUT THE
PRESIDENT WELL BEFORE THAT.
BUT FIRST.
THE DEMOCRATS MOOD SHIFT, THAT’S
THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S ANGLE.
WHAT A DIFFERENCE 24 HOURS
MAKES.
YESTERDAY DEMOCRATS AND THEIR
MEDIA ALLIES WERE POSITIVELY
GIDDY USING PHRASES LIKE
BLOCKBUSTER REVELATIONS,
BOMBSHELL LEAK, AND IMPEACHMENT
GAME CHANGER.
THEY WERE SURE THAT THE STORY
ABOUT JOHN BOLTON’S NEW BOOK
WOULD BE ENOUGH TO CONVINCE FOUR
REPUBLICANS TO KEEP THIS TWISTED
TRIAL GOING.
TODAY AFTER THE TRUMP DEFENSE
TEAM WRAPPED UP ITS ARGUMENTS
EVEN YIELDING BACK IN TIME TO
THE SENATE, THE MOOD ON THE LEFT
SEEMS TO HAVE SHIFTED.
OR SHOULD I SAY IT ADAM SHIFTED
TO.
>> I WAS MORE OPTIMISTIC
YESTERDAY MORNING THEN I AM NOW.
I TALKED TO SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES LAST NIGHT, A FEELING
I WAS GETTING WAS THEY ARE
LINKING ARMS AND THEY ARE GOING
TO SAY NO.
>> RIGHT NOW THE REPUBLICANS
FEEL GOOD TO.
>> THE UNIVERSE OF REPUBLICANS
HASN’T REALLY EXPANDED TO.
>> YOU ANTICIPATE THEY ARE GOING
TO VOTE AGAINST THE WITNESSES?
>> PREDICTIONS ARE DANGEROUS BUT
IT SEEMS UNLIKELY.
>> Laura: OLD BOY, THE FACES
WANT TO SAD OVER AT CNN, IF A
PICTURE IS WORTH A THOUSAND
WORDS AS THEY SAY,
CHUCK SCHUMER’S FACE READ LIKE A
NOVEL.
A LOT OF PAIN AND SUFFERING
THERE.
ON THE WITNESSES QUESTION, DOES
HE SOUND LIKE A MAN WHOSE PARTY
IS WINNING?
>> ONE AT A TIME.
[REPORTER QUESTIONING]
>> LOOK, I HOPE THAT WE HAVE
JUST FOUR REPUBLICANS, ALL WE
NEED IS FOUR WHO RISE TO THE
OCCASION AND SAY WE NEED TO FIND
OUT THE TRUTH.
>> Laura: CAN WE REDIRECT THAT
AGAIN?
>> ONE AT A TIME.
>> Laura: I’VE BEEN LOOKING
FOR A NEW RINGTONE AND THAT IS A
GOOD ONE.
WAIT, WHAT ABOUT THE FACES OF
THE HOUSE MANAGERS AFTER THE
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL FINISHED HIS
ARGUMENT?
THEY PUT IN ALL THAT TIME AND
EFFORT TRYING TO TAKE THE
PRESIDENT OUT OF OFFICE, WHERE
THEY BRIMMING WITH OPTIMISM?
ONLY IN THE LAND OF FRAUDULENT
IMPEACHMENT WITH THE LEAD HOUSE
MANAGER COMPLAIN THAT THE OTHER
SIDE DIDN’T SPEND MORE TIME
ARGUING THEIR CASE.
>> I WANT TO BEGIN THIS
AFTERNOON WITH A FEW
OBSERVATIONS ABOUT THE RATHER
ABRUPT END TO THE PRESIDENT’S
CASE.
IT’S CLEAR I THINK TODAY THAT
THEY ARE STILL REELING FROM THE
REVELATION OF JOHN BOLTON’S BOOK
AND WHAT HE HAS TO SAY.
>> Laura: COMPLAINING THAT THE
OTHER SIDE DIDN’T USE ALL THEIR
TIME.
AND THEN HE GRASPED ANOTHER
IRRELEVANT STRAW, SOMETHING THAT
JOHN KELLY SAID AT A SPEECH IN
FLORIDA?
>> THE PRESIDENT’S OWN FORMER
CHIEF OF STAFF GENERAL KELLY HAS
STATED THAT HE BELIEVES
JOHN BOLTON, THE PRESIDENT’S OWN
FORMER CHIEF OF STAFF BELIEVES
JOHN BOLTON AND BY IMPLICATION
DOES NOT BELIEVE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> Laura: I HAVE A QUESTION,
DID THE DEMOCRATS REALLY THINK
THIS WAS GOING TO WORK?
THEY WERE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
INVALIDATE THE LAST ELECTION AND
STEAL THE NEXT ONE BY SIGHT AND
PUBLIC STATEMENTS OF FORMER
WHITE HOUSE STAFFERS?
AND WITHOUT THE DEFENSE TEAM
TURNING THE TABLES ON THE HOUSE
MANAGERS?
>> BY THESE ACTIONS YOU WOULD
UNDO THE FREE ELECTION THAT
EXPRESS THE WILL OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, YOU WILL DAMAGE THE
FAITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE
IN THIS INSTITUTION AND IN THE
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY.
>> YOU WILL REAP THE BITTER
HARVEST OF THE UNFAIR PARTISAN
SEED YOU SOW TODAY.
>> THERE MUST NEVER BE A
NARROWLY VOTED IMPEACHMENT, IT
WILL PRODUCE DIVISIVENESS AND
BITTERNESS AND POLITICS FOR
YEARS TO COME.
>> MY FEAR IS WHEN A REPUBLICAN
WINS THE WHITE HOUSE, DEMOCRATS
WILL DEMAND PAYBACK.
>> Laura: EVEN THE RESISTANCE
MEDIA HAD TO ADMIT THAT USING
THE DEMOCRATS OWN WORDS AGAINST
THEM, IT WORKS.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS AN EFFECTIVE
SET OF ZINGERS AND I BET THE
REPUBLICANS REALLY ENJOYED
LISTENING TO IT.
>> IT WAS AWKWARD BECAUSE A LOT
OF WHAT THESE DEMOCRATS WERE
SAYING THEN, SPECIFICALLY
INCLUDED AT LEAST TWO OF THE
HOUSE MANAGERS, JERRY NADLER AND
ZOE LOFGREN, THEY SAY THE
OPPOSITE TODAY.
>> Laura: THAT’S CALLED
TURNING THE TABLES ON THEM.
FOR NOW THE LIBERAL MEDIA WAS
LEFT CLINGING TO THEIR NEW
LIFEBOAT AND THEN THEY MERELY
ECHOED WHAT SCHIFF SAID EARLIER
ABOUT KELLY.
>> JOHN KELLY SAYS HE BELIEVES
JOHN BOLTON’S CLAIM, HE THINKS
BOLTON IS A MAN OF INTEGRITY AND
SHOULD BE HEARD FROM.
>> Laura: LAST TIME I CHECKED,
GENERAL KELLY -- I LIKE HIM, I
THINK HE’S A GREAT GUY BUT HE’S
NOT A SENATOR WHO GETS TO VOTE
ON WITNESSES.
I THINK SOMEONE NEEDS TO SEND
THAT MEMO TO JERRY NADLER AS
WELL.
>> WHO ARE THE WITNESSES YOUR
SIDE WILL BE SEEKING?
>> JOHN BOLTON, MAYBE NOW
JOHN KELLY.
>> HAVE YOU DISCUSSED THE IDEA
OF CALLING GENERAL KELLY WITH
OTHER MANAGERS OR SENATORS?
>> NO.
>> Laura: OKAY, SO JOHN KELLY
A GUY WHO HASN’T BEEN AT THE
WHITE HOUSE FOR OVER A YEAR, NOW
HE’S GOING TO SAVE THE DEMOCRATS
IMPEACHMENT CRUSADE?
IF THAT DOESN’T WORK, THEY
ALWAYS HAVE THE QUINNIPIAC POLL.
>> THAT’S AN INTENSE CAUCUS
GOING ON RIGHT NOW, THEY ARE ALL
LISTENING TO EACH OTHER.
>> WHAT IS THE CHANCE THEY’VE
SEEN THE NEW 75 NUMBER FROM
QUINNIPIAC?
>> PRETTY GOOD.
TO DEPRIVE WITNESSES IS UTTER
INSANITY.
51-54% WHO ARE BEHIND HIS
IMMEDIATE REMOVAL BUT 75% FOR
WITNESSES IS POLITICAL SUICIDE.
>> Laura: 97% OF THE G.O.P. AS
OPPOSED TO REMOVING DONALD TRUMP
FROM OFFICE.
SO THOSE FOUR MODERATED G.O.P.
SENATORS WHO ARE WRINGING THEIR
HANDS TONIGHT AND NAVEL-GAZING,
THE HAMLET ROUTINE, THEY SHOULD
TAKE NOTE.
THIS IS HOW DONALD TRUMP WAS
RECEIVED WHEN A RECORD CROWD
SHOWED UP WHEN HE TOOK THE STAGE
AT A RALLY IN NEW JERSEY TONIGHT
TONIGHT.
[CHANTING]
WHO EXACTLY DO THEY THINK THEY
ARE APPEALING TO IF THEY TURN
OUT TO PROLONG THE IMPEACHMENT
FARCE?
THE PANEL IS THERE, CHUCK TODD,
JAKE TAPPER, ET CETERA -- THEY
DON’T HAVE THE VOTES TO REMOVE
TRUMP.
DEMOCRATS DON’T HAVE THOSE
VOTES, EVERYONE ON TELEVISION
WAS CONCEDING THAT TODAY.
SO WHAT IS THE POINT OF DOING
THIS TO THE COUNTRY?
AS THEY DID DURING THE
BRETT KAVANAUGH FIGHT, THEY WANT
TO DRAG THIS OUT IN HOPES THAT
THE NEXT NEWS CYCLE WILL BRING
THEM SOME MANNA FROM HEAVEN, THE
DAMAGE THE PRESIDENT BEFORE THE
FIRST BALLOTS ARE CAST.
OUR REPORTER TELLS US THEY ARE
SERVING DRINKS CALLED MAGARITAS
AND SUPEONACOLADAS ALL OVER
WILDWOOD NEW JERSEY.
SHOULD THEY PROLONG THIS
NATIONAL NIGHTMARE, THERE WON’T
BE ENOUGH BOOZE IN ALL OF
NEW JERSEY TO SOOTHE THE